uh if anything i'm saying doesn't make
sense
which is often especially if you ask my
wife but uh then feel free just to stick
your hand up and say something okay i've
worked for a whole load of places i've
done government retail manufacturing
i've been in this business for
really far too long now honestly and
briefly i was one of those contractors
your mum used to warn you about these
days i work for muller dairies
who um
they're awfully nice and they
occasionally provide free yogurt i like
that that's good stuff that is
uh right
but anyway i'm a film fan so i don't
have an agenda so much as a program of
events i'm going with who what where
when why how the slightly inaccurately
named 6ws
okay
first off who is functional programming
so i'll show you three gentlemen from
history who were significant to the
development of functional programming
one of these guys is a software
developer see if you can guess which one
this gentleman here is alonzo church
he invented a whole load of stuff that
i'm not clever enough to understand but
the important bits down the bottom here
this is a way of shorthanding a function
into a little thing with an arrow one
which we do in c sharp and particularly
of note is this guy here this is the
greek letter lambda used to indicate a
parameter which is where we get lambda
expressions from this guy
this is um uh haskell curry after whom
no fewer than three programming
languages are named amongst other things
he invented currying which i'll kind of
get into in a bit later he invented an
awful lot of the ideas which are then
later incorporated into functional
programming
could this guy be a software developer
he is
this is john mccarthy he arguably
invented the very first functional
programming language in the 1960s
that's it on the side lisp
something like list processing language
or something of that sort i'm told it
still has its fans to this day
personally never used it apparently it's
pretty wild and you can do some
extraordinary things with it
fine
but
so what is functional programming not
for a start the whole point
of the last few slides was to show that
functional programming is not new it's
really quite old
in fact the very beginnings of
functional programming go back to the
late 1800s sure it wasn't computed in
those days it was maths it was my i once
wasted most of a sunday tracking down
those old matte papers and realizing
that i'm not clever enough to read any
of them
but they do exist
and all of this stuff carried on in the
uh all the way through the 50s and then
finally in the 60s where it breaks into
the computing world
but my point is it's not like the latest
trendy javascript framework it is not a
thing that is here today and so much
fish and chip paper tomorrow as i say in
the uk it's it has been around for a
long time it will be around for a long
time
it is not a language it's a paradigm
so what's paradigm
if you want a metaphor if a programming
language is a guitar then a paradigm is
the style of music i play i could play
rock music i could play jazz i could
play country if i have no soul whatever
you get the idea there are different
styles of programming and functional is
one of them it is not imperative now
that's the other dominant paradigm by
with the other i mean it is the dominant
paradigm object orientated as a form of
imperative
the one of the big things that defines
imperative is that you are very
concerned with how things are done and
modifying state
piece by piece building things up and
being very particular about the order of
operations how things are done when etc
as i'll get to in a minute and
functional we're less concerned with
this
it's not the solution to all of your
problems it will not heat the coffee in
the morning but it'll do a lot of other
fun things and it's not difficult
this is a common myth about functional
that it's difficult it's not
in fact there are fewer things to learn
than there are for object-orientated
programming a lot of the folks that i
know that have been the most
enthusiastic about taking it up are
often university students who learned it
first before object orientated the folks
i know that tend to resist it the most
are the ones who've been dude object
orientated for a very long time and i
don't really want to take on a new uh a
new way of thinking which is fine
so what is it what actually is it
okay
it's declarative
now this is the alternative to
imperative what is declarative we've
probably done bits and pieces of it
before tsql is declarative
this is where you were less concerned
with
the precise details of how you build up
your object piece by piece when you are
writing tsql you write a select aware um
an order by a grouping etc do you care
which order they execute in i do not
it's not the order it's written in
if anyone's ever really dug into tsql
it's not the selector's last bit pretty
much
maybe-ish sorta but
honestly who cares
and that's one of the defining features
of a declarative programming language
you don't really care about the order of
execution you don't care about the
detail of how this is built up you
declare what you want and then let it
get on with it
immutable so
immutable means once a variable has been
set you can't change it again not ever
can we do this in c sharp i'll get to
that in a bit sort of meh
we'll get to that
higher order functions funky scary name
for a simple idea that most of us been
doing for years
functions passed around as variables
done there we go
why do people love to come up with scary
names for this stuff i do not know but
there you go functions passed around to
variables we've been doing it since what
c sharp three
uh function lot statement so what's a
statement
a statement something that changes the
order of the flow
if
where
for
all that stuff those are statements
generally speaking don't use them in
functional so
try and imagine a program without those
statements and you're somewhere close
but probably confused if you don't know
what we're going to do
we'll get to it we'll get to it bear in
mind and referential transparency once
again slightly scary name for something
quite simple
also known as pure functions so these
are
functions that are not allowed to rely
on anything except their own parameters
okay
the reason for that being amongst other
things it makes them more stable but
also incredibly incredibly testable the
whole point is that given the same
parameters in
you will always get the same answer out
no matter what no matter the state of
anything in the system no matter the
whole life of the universe no matter
what same variables in same answer out
that's why it's called referential
transparency you can kind of swap the
reference but yeah anyway
it's what it's called um
right recursion are we all good with
recursion i'm guessing we're all good
with recursion yeah yeah
going to be tough you meant more to a
bit later if it's not pattern matching
there was a time when i actually needed
to go into a great deal of detail about
this but we're now doing it in c-sharp
like full-on
since uh about c-sharp eight uh it's
basically switched statements with knobs
on yeah i've actually taken a load of
slides out because of the way things are
moved these days
stateless there is no state in a proper
functional language there's other
systems if anyone's used react you
probably have an idea of how we're going
to go about doing that
and monads monads that's the one that
everyone gets all a bit concerned about
when you start talking about well i
won't saw a talk by douglas crockford
which was actually about javascript but
he said that the curse of the moan ad is
that once you gain the ability to
understand it
you lose the ability to explain it
so i shan't
and it's not difficult i hope in about
40 minutes or so you'll agree with me
but who knows
so where is it my throat is getting dry
so where is it well there's the
functional languages there are pure
functional languages out there there's a
whole load of them haskell erlang see i
told you haskell there he is as if
there's one he does have them named
after him
they exist i know they have their their
fans i've heard haskell gets used a lot
in banking um elm erlang i've heard of
uses of them
if anyone's ever used rabbit mq that's
that's written in a pure functional
language so they are they exist they're
out there i've never used them
personally but fair play to those guys
that do
hybrid languages java i think java as
often as the case was the first to uh to
jump onto this particular boat uh java c
sharp they said it's python these days
you can do it in c plus plus as well you
name it pretty much an awful lot of
languages support both paradigms
uh i should probably mention f sharp at
this point yes there is a net language
which is pure um it's not purely
functional but it's
way more over to the functional side
than c sharp is way more and it's it's
cool
i've never worked in it personally
if anyone wants to go ahead and do it go
for it do it it compiles to the same net
runtime behind the scenes so it is
entirely cross-compatible with c-sharp
with db.net
now at some point in one of these talks
somebody usually asks me why don't we
just use f sharp
okay
here's my answer hands up if you know c
sharp
hands up if you know f sharp
there is my answer
that's a little facetious
but uh my point being not that f sharp's
not well cool it is well cool it is not
that f sharp cannot do everything it can
do everything
it's more that
in a professional environment where
you've got a team you've got to keep
your team full of people and so on it is
a much bigger and more complicated
investment to decide we're going to
commit to f sharp than to c sharp
because c sharp developers up to a penny
and f sharp is a much rarer skill
but to be honest if my boss said
tomorrow we've heard about f sharp we
want to go for it i'd be on board i'd be
there for it i would do it the little
bit of tinker i've done with that sharp
made it look awesome but i don't
personally know how to do it so anyway
that's why this is functional c sharp
a javascript yes javascript javascript
the wild west of programming javascript
supports everything and nothing because
everything is everything else but also
nothing but also a function but also an
empty array but also text
possibly except when it isn't
because javascript
so yeah okay when is it when is it good
okay it is good anything you can do
anything with it but when i say when
what i mean is these are the things
where it's happiest it is a paradigm
based around predictability on the same
things resulting from the same inputs so
these are the places where you tend to
get your best results data processing
chunk this data to this data great at
that
concurrent systems higher yeah because
there is no state there is no state
therefore it much better supports the
idea of having a whole load of parallel
processes going off there's no shared
state because there is no state so i'm
not saying that you don't get race
conditions because i'm sure it's always
possible in any complex system but you
don't tend to get the problems of
resource contention you might get in
other languages
and criticality
functional programs are more robust than
object orientated
you tend to get some applications that
will go up and generally never come down
there are programming there are pure
functional languages out there which say
and i've got no reason to doubt them but
once these things actually stand up you
can't kill them shorter pressing the
power button on the server
and that is probably true now c-sharp
can't probably ever quite claim that
file but they are more robust so if you
need this thing to go up and stay up
this may be the talk for you and
serverless again parallel processing
uh stateless if you're interested in
going to the serverless route this will
support it strongly
so when is it not again
not that it can't do these things but
this is where it's less good and this is
things where you've got impurity
co-sneaking in and particularly things
like external interactions ui there is
nothing more impure than a human being
this is where compromises have to be
made now i like to think of the metaphor
of a shadow a shadow has well broadly
speaking two parts yes i know there's
about 14 if you look it up but there's
broadly two there's the umbra the big
dark bit in the middle and then the pen
umbra the sort of gray fuzzy bit around
the outside so if you want to my goal
when i am writing functional c sharp is
to maximize the purely functional bit
that is the umbra the dark bit and
minimize the sort of fringy bits around
the outside where we've actually got to
accept that
there is a real world that we need to
interact with so that's that's kind of
like a caveat
so why i touched on some of these it is
concise that's not a small thing
how much of our lives do we spend
looking at code and wondering what does
this do
you know i i i support code bases that
are upwards of 20 years old
i've seen one or two that aren't even
that old and really how did they get
into that state i will never know but it
happens functional tends to be more
concise tends to be easier to write and
the patterns that we follow in
functional tend to be such that it
discourages some of the poor coding that
i've seen in some of those code bases
i've worked on
it is readable it is testable and this
for some people is the one this is one
of the features for a lot of people it
is it is incredibly testable and
predictable and that's a great thing
it was concurrently touching that robust
touch that is fine i think it's fun i
think it's fun if no other reason i'm
incredibly lazy and what i really love
is not spending an awful lot of time
doing code that i don't need to write
and this bypasses a whole load of
boilerplate that i can't be bothered to
write
so let's get on with it bit of
functional code how do we do it this is
not functional code this is a bit of
good old-fashioned object-orientated
this is the same sort of thing i have to
stare at every day sort of thing that
probably a few of us could guess what it
does in a few moments but do you need
developers like to stare at it for a
while it's uh it's like looping
splitting it's it's adding things to a
list and how would this look
functionally well you get a hint there
because you can see resharper's already
trying to tell me look like that
so if anyone's about to say that looks
like a whole big pile of link that's a
whole big pile of link
and
not everyone realizes this but link is
functional
link is entirely based in the functional
paradigm
when
you write a link expression you are
passing in an arrow function which is of
course is a function it's a function
passed around as a parameter that's a
higher order function
when you
perform a select on an array
it's not modifying the original array
it is creating a copy of it based on the
old one so the old array is immutable
it's functional and it's been around
since what c sharp four
granted there was a little bit of gap
before we got many more functional
features after that but link was the
start link is the beginning of c sharp
supporting both paradigms so
my goal in a way is to turn the whole of
c sharp into something that looks rather
like link so if like me you think that
link's one of the best features of
c-sharp which i honestly think it is
then hopefully gonna enjoy the rest of
the talk
but uh there we go that's simple and the
nice thing is easy to read there's a
logical order of operations it's easy to
throw something in take something out
it's simpler to know what it's doing
and um
it's it's not yeah i like it i think
it's more elegant and try adding a whole
bunch of extra ridiculous logic into
that you can't it's a it's a link thing
see
right anyway moving on
this is something that when i used to
work for the tax people in the uk i had
to look for an awful lot this is a
validation for a nino
anyone know what a nino is it's less
likely to be something people know over
here it's a national insurance number uh
it's like a code that you have to give
in when you're paying your tax it has a
whole load of ridiculous validation
logic and what i've got here is a great
big long function there's a whole load
of early returns i don't know if anyone
can see that here we go checking each
rule if the rule's not followed return
false early and then finally at the
bottom which oh it's missing for some
reason there's a return troop just trust
me it's there
so how would i turn this into something
that looks vaguely functional
like this actually
so this is putting funks
into an array which you can totally do
and once you start doing things like
that you can do some interesting stuff
um can anyone see my code by the way not
used to such a big room right
so i'll try and describe what we've got
here we've got a series of functions up
here i've just i've described them
separately there just for the sake of
readability for my code base i've got
one that says must have a length of nine
which is x going to x dot length is nine
this is must start with an alphanumeric
and i've got a regex the rest of areas
are the red x's it's not really that
important what these are
but here i'm sticking them all literally
just into an array and then here
i'm calling dot all
now that's a link expression so we
haven't really done a very great deal to
c sharp at the moment but that is dot
all
so and inside the dot all what i'm
saying is take the original nino that is
national insurance number
and then feed it into whatever x is now
x in this case now is a function all of
these functions are strings to bools
each one's about so what does this mean
what this means is it's going to go
through each one of these in turn
execute and all means that every single
one must return true
if a single one returns false the entire
all statement fails out
so all of that ridiculous boilerplate on
the previous slide is now captured in
the structure of this all
and that's so much easier
you could also do it like this you could
write an extension method i am actually
quite a fan of extension methods they
get a big rap a bad rap i don't think
that's entirely fair just don't put any
business logic in them that's the way of
doom but other than that extension
methods are awesome and so i've created
myself a little extension method which
takes everything and takes the list of
predicates that being things that turn
whatever into a bull and then runs them
all so that means i've now got a
validate function hanging off almost
everything and i could just call
validate and then list all my validate
rules wow
imagine writing that long hand take it
ages
this is another kind of example of how
you use higher order functions this
isn't we call this alto you could call
this i've seen this called a few things
but alt is as good as any so in this
case i've got two funks
they wouldn't really be funks in the
real world imagine their database
operations or text based file lookups
whatever i don't really mind but the
point is that this one here number one
works uh you're given a string and it
will give you back uh this works plus
whatever you just said the second one
here is this doesn't work and it's
returning a null
so the point is i've got two ways of
looking up a bit of data as i say this
could represent maybe a web api and
maybe a file based alternative
and one of them works and one of them
fails okay and in an alt scenario what
you do is input which is my name as it
happens
called alt and then pass it the two
different methods and what it will do is
try the first one then try the other one
and this will actually work so i'm
passing in both operations the first one
that doesn't work first and it doesn't
fail it will not break it will not
return null
that's how you do it
so first off my alt which is
uh an alter of input
t input to t output attaching to t input
which means it attaches to everything
and taking two function one and your two
which turn input to output
and i've created another extension
called if default do which just says
attach to everything again check whether
it's null and if it's null
do the other thing do the other thing
i'm passing in which is the other
function now this here is the long
slightly scary way of actually checking
null
when you're dealing with generics
because not everything defaults to no
integers don't booleans don't you know
the song
okay
and last one of these this is a fork
so a fork is based on the idea that you
have a single input then you have many
prongs of your fork each of which do a
separate operation and then you have
something at the end which sticks all
the prongs back together again
so this is a ridiculous example and why
would you ever do this but i'm just
demonstrating
uh so i've got this great big long
string it's actually based on one of the
um exercises from the the advent of
codes and i'll do that i love the advent
of code that is my december burnout that
i go through every year at about the
13th of december that's usually about as
far as i get at which point i'd either
collapse in a nervous wreck on the floor
because of how much i'm working or stop
doing the advent of code now but anyway
um
so what i'm saying is here this is
positive fascinating function which is
going to stick everything together which
is a sum in my case and then each fork
is going to each prong is going to count
a different item and a's b's and c's and
again why would i ever do this in the
real world but my point is you can get
one input many calculations then stick
them together again again it's a sort of
we're separating out the structure of
the code from what you actually the
specifics of what you're passing into it
and that's how you do it it's just same
sort of thing again
we've got our funks we are
this is map which is one of those great
tools you never really noticed you
needed it's just a simple simple
extension method which attaches to
everything and takes a funk that turns
old thing to a new thing what it means
is you can kind of like do a select
except it selects the whole object at
one time instead of selecting each
element of an array it's the whole
object
so i find it very useful
and then the fork is just
take the the join and then a params so
you can stick as many prongs as you like
each of which is a funk
so these are the sorts of fun things you
can do when you start playing around
with the idea of higher order functions
that is functions passed around as
parameters
so moving on to a different area this is
this is one of those um examples that
you get in an awful lot of
object-orientated books this is bank
accounts
so i'm going to imagine that there's a
standard bank account which has got a
balance and an interest we'll inherit on
that with the super duper one which has
got a bonus interest and then after that
the dodgy one which has got a brown
paper bag of money presumably passed in
a car park now insert the name of a
politician you don't care for at this
point i'm not going to name a name i
know i'm thinking oh man but
you feel free knock yourself out
so i'll have different rules for each of
these bank accounts
now this was one of the bits that when i
started doing this talk was quite
revolutionary but these days becoming a
little more normal
so there we go switch statement in
rel not the very latest c sharp but
there's the the early version which is
still really well cool
and this is switching on types if anyone
hasn't seen this go play with it
you're switching here on the type
not on the um
not on the values within it so i'm
passing in
a base bank account i can switch on
whether it's actually a dodgy bank
account and then wrap it into a local
variable here so that means that if it
really is one of those subtypes it will
hit this case and then it will be
wrapped into this local object so i
could bypass all of that tedious
checking with if type double equals and
then doing um
doing some uh some switching of types
and all that sort of thing does it all
for us there's a lot of boilerplate now
we just don't need to write anymore and
you could also stick in a when to be
specific about the properties of the of
the class now as of the very more recent
versions of c sharp
it looks actually more like this
which is even cooler
and one of my favorite features since
the most recent cool features
and
it's a much nicer syntax we're we're
bordering on something that looks a lot
like json now and this is also
incredibly cool this is a default over
here the underscore
now as of c 11 which isn't out yet it
looks like they're planning to enhance
this sort of feature even further
so there's talk of pattern matchings
which match on the elements of arrays
which sounds brilliant so things like
switch on this l array is empty or
switch on this array starts with this
element and then ends in this element
that sort of stuff sounds well cool
and i can imagine that might be useful
for dealing with things like
serialized data files and stuff like
that but
as far as i'm aware it's not all
finalized and i don't and c-sharp 11
comes at the end of the year i think so
watch this space for for an update to
these slides again at some point
mutability so we talked about
immutability can you do immutability in
c sharp like i said the answer the short
answer is
the long answer is this
so
this is immutable it is
these are an int and a string
i have got a getter i have no setter i
am setting them within the
within the constructor so sure
this is immutable no worries
is this a mutable
so i have now added an i list here type
c now it's still got no setter is it
immutable
no no it's not
because i can still call the dot add
so it's not
i could change it like this there we go
mutable array there we go sorted it's
immutable now that's fine you can pass
in as many lists as you like you can't
change it so we're good
how about this
i've now got a subclass i don't know
what subclass is i've called it subclass
because i don't care
is this immutable well actually i don't
know i don't know
does subclass actually implement
immutability i don't know
and this gets even more complicated when
you start dealing with things like third
party libraries
uh stuff that is well outside of your
control so
frankly it's a little bit of a pipe
dream immutability in c-sharp
i mean
yes we have this feature which is you
can stick nullable at the tag at the top
of your file and it won't actually make
things immutable it'll just put a
compiler warning here if you try to make
things null so does that i suppose your
stuff like that and it'll it might look
like this it might give you warnings if
you if you try to put null in into
statements like this it'll it'll give
you a compiler warning and warning
you're about to make something null
that's good it's not terrible it's not
immutability though yeah you can also
put in um where is it either ago you put
exclamation mark in there as a i'm which
is a flag to say i'm a grown-up no i
really do want to make it null because i
don't know why you'd want to do that but
you do
you could set it globally like this
which again is mostly dealing with the
problems of null ability
not the same as immutability so this is
a good feature there you go
um this is probably about a one of the
closer ways we can get to it that is
using init properties
yes it's still not really immutable
because i just don't think we can do it
not really
basically my approach
is to pretend
just basically pretend that immutability
exists and acts like it does
but it doesn't
i mean fundamentally c sharp is not a
pure functional language it never will
be that is not on the cards and for
backwards compatibility reasons i don't
think they're ever going to implement
true immutability it's just not going to
happen if it means a lot to shift to f
sharp
that will solve your problems f sharp
short it's a mutable there but um c
sharp i don't think it's ever going to
be but you could still behave like it is
nothing stopping you
so this is another feature which has
come in c-sharp just recently and this
is my most favorite feature since the
other features
this is a record type has anybody played
with record types
they are pure awesome on toast aren't
they
i love them
the whole
the whole idea of a record type is that
um
amongst other things
you can create a new record so record
when i say records in class they're
pretty much the same thing as classes
ish
except they have one amazing feature and
that is i can create a new one
from the old one with one change
that's well cool
it makes it an awful lot easier to
pretend really hard that immutability
actually exists because i could do stuff
like this so i'm doing a switch
statement on
this is a totally made-up example where
i've got a person class
and i'm saying that there is an update
operation enum which is telling me the
different kinds of updates i could do
this is totally made up but it's just to
demonstrate
and i'm saying if it's a first name then
here we go p with first name equals
whatever
so my param here which is a string could
equal any of the fields to be updated
but the with statement is the thing that
says
take a copy of the old person
return a new person which is identical
except with the changes i just
said that is one of the most boilerplate
saving changes that have been in c-sharp
for absolutely ages and it makes it very
very easy to implement something close
to proper immutability because that's
generally the way i do it
when instead of going for this sort of
object-orientated method of passing my
class by reference change it inside
which i do not like it makes me feel
squeamish
instead i tend to make a replica of the
old one and then return the new one and
this makes it incredibly simple to do
that so record types check them out if
you haven't already they are smashing
so i did talk about carrying
here we go
so what is carrying
we're about to find out if anyone in the
audience knows
this is a hypothetical ad function
a plus b there we go nothing
controversial there
if this was a hype an actual curried
function so well if it was non-carried
function i could give it 10 and 20 and
i'd get 30. no worries there
what if i were only to give it 10
and it was a curried function
can anyone take a guess at what the heck
i get back out of that
it get yeah a function you'd get back a
function now there's a rule of thumb
in functional programming if there is a
question the answer's functions
it's mostly true
it's always more functions that's way by
the way it's called functional
programming it's not because the other
stuff doesn't work
which arguably but it's not
it's because it's all based on functions
like lego bricks or sort of piled on top
of each other so yeah if you passed in a
10 to a curried add function with two
parameters what you get back is an add
10 function
so a function where the one parameter
has been filled in so can we do that in
c sharp
you can do it like this this is one
method
so i do do this sometimes um even if
it's quite clear but we've got two
arrows arrow one arrow two
and what this is this is an add a
subtract to multiply divide so these are
your basic mathematical operations
what i've got basically is like a
factory which produces more functions
that's kind of close to carrying in
principle
but it means you literally have to apply
the parameters in order one at a time
you know it's it's not perfect but
so what it means is if you call this
thing this add you give it 10 here what
you're actually getting back
is this
x plus y where the x has already been
filled in
you can you can do that and sometimes i
do it for the sake of if nothing else
occasionally it looks a little bit more
descriptive than sticking in long arrow
expressions
there are other ways
so this is what's called an example of
how you might do a partial application
it's called which is where you fill in
say two or more parameters at the same
time you can do it like this so this is
a list of
doctor who stories now doc i don't know
if doctor who's well known over here in
portugal but it is um the best tv series
in the entire world it actually is if
you look in the dictionary you'll find
it right there with a big picture of the
tardis and everything
i'll fight you if you say otherwise i'll
meet you
so this is um a list of the first very
very very first series episode from 1963
starring the boss william hartnell
and we've got it in csv format i've got
the code the serial number of the
episode it's
the um the title of the episode and how
many episodes it was comprised of okay
and here i've got a great big long
parser
and it's got four parameters i've got
the take the thing the actual string the
whole string is one parameter what do i
split the lines by which is newline in
my case what do i split the fields by
which is commas in my case and so on so
you fill all four of those parameters
out and what you get back and then
finally which bit of data of this array
i'm actually interested in
you fill all those in and basically you
like get an extra list of the episodes
or something
but wouldn't it be neat if i didn't have
to write a different one of these
for wanting to do a summary of each
different column of data well you can
with a partial application
which sadly looks absolutely horrendous
and i'll show you it in a minute
but here
is how you might use one so up here
we've got our array
so then i'll do dot apply which is how i
might do my partial application to fill
in some of the parameters so what i've
applied here is the new line being the
uh thing i split the lines by and the
comma which is what the fields by so
what i've now created is a parser
function which feed it any csv it'll
split by line in comma and you get back
an array of arrays and i can reuse that
as many times as i like
then i could um apply with an additional
parameter to say i'm interested in the
zeroth
um
field out of out of this list of stuff
you got so now what i've got is a
function which give it a big long csv
you get back a list of all the serial
codes and here i could call it again and
pass in a one to say i'm interested in
the first the number one field to get
back a list of the episode titles
what it means in short is i wrote one
parser function
by partially applying bits at a time i
can create a sort of tree of a whole
load of functions all of which do all
sorts of things in a sort of inheritance
like scenario
but i still only write one function
it's a way of reusing code to a
ridiculous extent it's really cool it
can be done
but it's hideous
like hideous that's what it looks like
so it totally can be done and what
basically i'm doing is taking a funk as
a parameter and returning a different
funk
filling in what this also means is
because we're not all that fluid in c
sharp with how many parameters into how
many parameters out for every single
combination of how many parameters in to
how many out i've got to write another
one of these
so you could basically write a novel
length code bear file to make it happen
you can all power to you if you want to
do it but yeah it looks a bit hideous
so a functional flow a sort of standard
function of flow we start with one thing
split it into many things
filter it a bit turn it into something
else and then the final bit the final
bit is aggregation
now
there was a time when i thought surely
this is not terribly controversial or
terribly unknown but it astonishes me
how many people don't realize he can do
this sort of stuff quite easily in c
sharp
turning many things into one thing
it's actually really ridiculously easy
in c sharp
there we go this is how i see most
people doing this as a string builder
which is looping through my doctor who
stories and like preparing a list adding
a comma we've got an if statement there
to make sure that you don't end up with
a comma after the very last item because
that looks kind of funny
and what we should end up with like a
list of uh
of all the stories with a comma except
the last one and a new line in between
them
i could do a string.giant
i mean
yeah i love string.join but how come
nobody knows about it i don't understand
but anyway that's string.join that's a
slightly easy example
what if i want to do something more it's
complicated
this is my hypothetical um
list of doctor who stories
so i've got the serial number
i've got the title i've got the rating
i've got the number of episodes because
in the old days each story was many
episodes and how many are missing now
sad story there are 97 episodes of
doctor who that are missing if any of
you happen to have them please please
please hand them back because i'd like
to see them again please especially if
it's fury from the deep that one's cool
anyway
what if i wanted to create um a report
which was a um some sort of
percentage-based thing based on the
number of episodes existing to not for
the stories and you could totally do
that in
all sorts of ways we can do a sum a sum
is just how you get the number of
episodes that's again link
uh some there but then there's averages
if you want to get average ratings
that's the easy stuff still fairly
standard link
there's the more complicated version
again i am astonished by how many people
don't know about this
aggregate
this is the grown-ups version of all the
rest of that
so this is where you're not just going
with a simple sum a simple average or
whatever you're specifying your own
entirely different behavior i use this
flipping tons and this is again based in
the functional paradigm it's i think it
actually uses recursion behind the
surface and um
what you do is set a c value
you see value is what you're starting
with now in my case i'm using tuples
tuples is how many total are missing to
how many total overall of episodes and
then inside that you provide another
function which says based on the current
item that being like your ex in a select
and the running total that being what
i've processed so far what is the new
running total so given this episode the
new um number of total missing episodes
is equal to whatever the old total was
plus the new episode set and again over
here and then we end up with
what from an array of data about missing
doctor who stories we end up with a
single value with all of the values
summed uh in a nice handy easy form now
this is a silly silly simple example but
i have put some very complicated logic
into some of these in the past for
preparing reports and for getting final
values out of things i recently put
together um
an application for work for covid19 data
and we used aggregate quite a lot in
that because it's it's so much easier
simple and quick and
faster right compared to the
alternatives
so
one of my last sections i'm going to
talk about time
not too bad right
i used to work for an american company
and there is a bit of a cliche about
british people and that is that we like
to talk about the weather it is true we
do we talk about weather all the time
partly because we have never a clue what
the weather is going to be an hour from
now
that's roughly how it works in the uk so
you there is a saying you can get four
seasons in a single day and it's
probably true
so my american colleagues would say
things like i'm not going to do the
accent i can't but they would say things
like 100 degrees outside and i think 100
degrees that is the boiling point of
water how are you still alive
no no no no they mean fahrenheit oh
fahrenheit that thing i don't understand
great how do i convert it well what is
the conversion for fahrenheit to celsius
it is deduct 32 multiplied by 5 divided
by 9 of course it is simple
but here i have my little
converter
function i'll do each of those
operations one after the other
and i'll do a math.round so i've got a
more sensible figure and then finally
i'll can put it into a string put degree
centigrade it looks pretty good now
that's fine nothing wrong with that
there are better ways of writing this
though there's a more functional way of
writing this
this is something called an identity
it's a thing in a box
thing in a box think of a box what's in
the box spoiler so
what is this so identity of t
meaning t is anything it could be
whatever like i said finger box
and that is how i get it that's how i
set it because it's mutable kinda
a bit of syntactic sugar just to mean
that i can easily pull it out the box
without having to bother to call dot
value easy peasy
and i'll write in an extension method
the first one there is to just turn
anything into an identity
and then the second one here is called
bind i've seen this
called all manner of things i've heard
it called map i've heard it called all
sorts i don't really care what it's
called but the point is this is like a
select it's like a select in link except
once again it operates on the whole
object
okay you could use bind on an integer
and then this is saying your arrow
statement is saying turn the old integer
into something else there are two um
generic parameters so old type to new
type i can quite happily shift from a
string to an intent to a string provided
whatever is inside this funk
does that transformation i don't care
but if you fed it an enumerable you will
see the whole innumerable at once
because it operates on the whole object
and that's all that is
and that's what that looks like oh and
uh the other thing is it takes the value
out of the old identity and then returns
a new one with the so basically take it
out this box
do a thing put it in this box and then
send it on its way that's what it does
that's what it looks like
so i'll take my decimal input
convert it into an identity bind
subtract 32 c there you go carrying i
told you i use it
subtract 32 multiply by five divide by
nine math.round whoa done
and all of those transformations are
stored in this there is none of those
little there are none of those
modifications of state i don't have to
create a little local variable i
literally use once and chuck away which
isn't a small thing
because i have seen functions that
stretch over thousands of lines of code
and things defined at the top still in
scope at the bottom so we've got a great
big object defined up here still in
scope down here
if you do it like this
when you run that bind and you run this
multiply this multiply function the
moment that this binds has run out of
scope subject for garbage collection so
it's quite clean in that regard you are
actually getting automatic cleanup of
your your uh cluttered stack so it's not
a terrible thing this is the simplest
example and by the way the name for this
structure is monad
so if anyone was ever curious that's
what they are
in a box
uh it's kind of like a relay race think
of it that way it's a relay race
your person is is running around the
track doing their thing handing over the
torch next person runs around the track
they might do a different thing it's a
funny relay race in that regard everyone
runs a different track but still the
principle is sound
that in and of itself is not actually
terribly useful really
but this is where we can add a level of
complication which will make it
more apparent what this is bringing to
you okay this is another example
so i'm getting a person id i'm running
this hypothetical function which is
getting a person
and
then i'm calling a series of binds so
based on my person i'll take their first
name and their last name and their age
i'll replace a's with fours e's with
threes eyes with ones o's with zeros
because that is what we call leap speak
and that's because i'm cool and that's
where i talk because the kids still do
leak speed don't they no
yeah yeah yeah because we're cool
right
but here's a problem
what if my get person 2 there
didn't find anybody what if it returned
null what happens inside this bind
explosion
no reference exception that doesn't
happen in functional programming and
i'll show you why so this isn't actually
an identity like the last monad this is
a different one this is called maybe
and this is the simplest useful monad
that exists pretty much
all the time because it's
tedious for me
okay
a maybe there and it's roughly the same
as our identity there's an abstract this
is an abstract now not a class it's an
abstract
now a bit about projection plus i'm a
big loudmouth mate am i on am i on
oh well good right sorry yes scott
vlasin scotland very good website by the
way it's actually an f sharp website but
there's a lot of very good stuff on it
for all sorts of stuff
like this slightly more philosophical oh
yeah there we go can you that is loud
isn't it
right i was having so much fun i didn't
notice right uh but the point is imagine
this right he calls it railway
orientated architecture so imagine that
you've got a railway running along
and you've got two tracks you've got the
happy track the something track and
you've got the nothing track underneath
it and every now and then you've got a
set of points going along like this
and these points are your your bind
functions
and what it means is at each point
the bind runs it transforms the old
thing to the new thing but also there's
a check involved that says did it work
did it explode was there something
coming out of this if there was
something if we still got something we
move along again and then we'll move on
and we move on if at any point
something failed or nothing came out you
switch
you switch to the nothing track and if
you're on the nothing track
you don't do any more work you just
glide along to the end
that's what that looks like this is my
modified bind function looks like this
so there's a switch statement in there
and i'm checking that whatever came out
of this this is always now a maybe which
i remember the maybe might be something
or nothing so i'm checking was it
something was it null
and if it was not null or whatever and
it was a something that means we've
actually got something we can operate on
in which case i'll run the function i'll
run the function grab the value stick it
in another maybe send it on
all other circumstances result in a
nothing coming out of this
or i'll also put a try catch in there
so if we go back to our example what
this would mean is so let's imagine that
null comes out of this
so this is a maybe this is something
we've got an
integer
this is a get person2 now this is
actually converting it to like a person
object
but let's imagine that null comes out of
it well um my but this year at this
point it's still a something this will
come out and this is a something at this
point
but it's something with a null attached
this bind will say
check this is it something yeah it is
but it's got null in it i'm not going to
execute this function
so i'll just pass it along i'll just
pass the empty box on to the next guy
this one will do the same empty box pass
it on empty box empty box empty box
imagine if i didn't do that imagine all
the if statements i'd have to write
imagine the length of code just to try
and defend myself from nulls and no
reference exceptions
that all of that error checking
is now contained in the structure of my
code and i don't need to bother to write
it ever again
and goodness me the amount of code extra
i would have written if i didn't have
this is phenomenal
this is one of the best code saving
tools i've ever come across so i'd
thoroughly recommend this and then at
the end of it i would probably do a
switch statement that just says at the
end did i have something or nothing and
in fact what i often do in my interfaces
is when it's a database lookup i will
actually return something along the
lines of task maybe person data
task because it's async maybe because i
don't know if it returned something or
not
and what i'm saying if i put it in the
interface is
i don't know if this works i'm giving
you a container which might or might not
contain something
your alternative which is what i tend to
see people do is you create your own
custom
return type which has got object and a
boolean or something that says it worked
or it didn't
this is doing all that for you don't
need to do it again it's a structure you
can use
there's an uh
what's that one oh yes my baby okay
there's a there's another alternative
which is more actually close to what i
really use in production we call it
either we've got a left and a right same
principle left is bad right is good
because of some sort of old tradition
and
in the left which is the one where it
didn't work i'll also capture an
exception
so if any point an exception occurred
i'll capture it in the monad even though
there's a whole load more binds
following it i will still capture the
last point where it worked i'll capture
the exception and the last state of
whatever it was that was held there and
then i can log that and we can know
exactly how to recreate the problem
easy peasy
and yeah it's another slightly more
complicated
okay
another question i asked a lot but
here's an answer are there any
frameworks out there that already
implement this stuff yes there are
this is language x it does most of this
stuff that's what language it's a little
small i apologize i could put this up
everyone's interested it looks very
similar to what i just wrote it's not
quite the same
one difference is that they use map not
bind and they force you at the end of
the maps to give two different functions
which will force it to collapse into
something at the end and that's fine
that's fine
personally i quite like rolling my own
as it were because if nothing else it
gets me used to the way to do all this i
you know it's a nice insight into how
how this all works what the system is
and it's not a lot of code really
usually you write a teeny little bit of
funky code and then you can reuse it all
over the place and do incredible things
so
but yeah languagex a lot of people like
it i don't use it
further reading places you can go
the best book on programming i've read
in a very long time is called functional
programming c-sharp it's by enrico
buenano
um he has yet to reply to me ever on
twitter
but it's cool it's published by manning
second edition now available
there is a book by vizno angoro
published by pat it's okay it's not
quite as good as the banana book but
it's there it's whatever you wanted the
actual first time i was ever exposed to
functional programming was ndc oshlo it
was a taught by kathleen dallard
called function c sharp and that was the
first time i've introduced the idea of
functional and my journey has been
continuing ever since
there are talks on pluralsight there's
scott valashen's website which is
absolutely worth checking out even if
you're never going to pick up f sharp it
is still worth browsing
um
now small announcement which i think is
something of an exclusive uh for you
folks i'm writing a book
uh that's it that's my book it's not
actually the final cover i don't i'm
writing this for o'reilly uh it's going
to be called functional program with c
sharp written by well me
um if anybody wants to scan this this is
a discount code that'll get you a 30-day
trial with o'reilly's learning platform
i can stick this back up if you wanna
have a look at it again later feel free
dig in they gave me this it's all legit
uh
so
this is currently available in
pre-release right now on the o'reilly
website there are currently two chapters
and the prelude
made available to the public
no spoilers the butler did not do it
but
roughly the plan is to release about a
chapter a month up until around december
and then we'll be getting somewhere
close to actually releasing this thing
in paper so if you want a dead tree copy
that'll be next year but anyway i am
writing a book but in the absence of
that uh there are plenty of other good
books but you know i wrote this one
any questions any questions at this
point
that's not my baby by the way
sir
i'm sorry i'm uh
uh my hearing's not very good
that's my fault
one off
one off yes it's kind of um
kind of a maybe kind of library uh just
kind of the same sort of stuff i was
just wondering if you try that out in
this kind of context okay no i have
never heard of it i'm afraid um i'll
certainly have a look at it as i said my
tendency is i um the maybe concept is so
simple i just made my own and the nice
thing there is i can customize it to be
whatever i want i tend to hang like
little extra um on events hanging off it
so i'll write my my long stream of maybe
by my mind and i'll do like
on error and on success and stuff at the
end so i like to write my own
functionality so no i haven't
i'm sure it's worth checking out but
i've never seen it but uh what do you
say it was called again uh one of one
off i will check it out i think one of
the things um about it is also like some
code generation underneath i was
wondering like kind of a performance
in this context that is that
thing you yeah okay performance yeah
that's a fair question
this is probably not the sort of code
i've shown you is probably not optimal
is that a problem generally no that's
reason being it is an awful lot easier
for me to write my lovely code that's
easy to maintain and then just chuck a
whole bucket of cpu and ram at it than
it is for me to write
optimal code so
i've seen i know there are books a high
performance c sharp but generally the
more optimal you co get the less
readable it gets so
it is true that you could probably write
more optimal code but unless you're
working like mobile apps or somewhere
where performance is 100 the focus of
your business i know places there are
there are a place like that then i don't
honestly really care like it is the
furthest thing my main concern is
can i really maintain this quickly and
easily and get the business requirement
out the door fast
and i'd say this supports that but
i would say performance wise it's not
horrible
it's not terrible nothing wrong with it
my kobe 19 app that got hit by one of
the highest rates of traffic in the
whole history of the business not long
ago wrote it entirely functionally it
was fine
it was fine so it's it's okay it's fine
not optimal maybe but it's fine if
finances you have your question sir yeah
it does thanks
um does anyone else have any more
questions sir
that aren't functional okay the question
was do i have any tips for implementing
functional programming existing toe
bases prayer no
to be honest i would just do it a bit at
a time most of the techniques i've show
shown for the most part with the odd
exception things like pattern matching
those will work on nearly any version of
c sharp going back to about c sharp four
so i just put in a bit at a time and a
bit at a time at a bit at a time the the
maybe thing i would stick that in a code
file at the back of your code base
somewhere somewhere you don't really
care about it daddy's like the
hypothetical snuff from thundercats
action figure that you own don't want to
admit to but it's kind of there in a box
and then shove that at the back and then
just start using it i wouldn't go and
plunder the whole code base and mod
multiple whole thing i just whenever you
make a change you do it this way or if
you see a quick win do it this way maybe
you've written a new function but make
it maybe the return time and start doing
it in a monad monadical is that a word i
think i just invented that word uh wait
if you see what i mean bit by bit by bit
by bit if nothing else it gets the rest
of your team used to it
so rather than bing bang change
everything which is probably just gonna
annoy everyone uh any further questions
no going once going twice
i declare this meeting the midnight
society in order thank you
yeah
that's my twitter account by the way
feel free if anyone wants it
you